CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, what
I want to work on
is using what we know
about matrix multiplication
and finding inverses of matrices
to solve a system of equations.
So we've set up
the system already
as if it's already
in matrix form.
And what I'd like us to do
is, for this particular A--
this 3-by-3 matrix A-- find a
vector x, so that A*x equals b.
Where b is equal to
these two things.
So you're going to
do two problems.
You're going to do when b
equals 1, 2, negative 3.
And you're going to do when
b is equal to [0, 0, 0].
So you want to find vector x
so that A*x equals this value
here.
And what I'd like
you to do is I'd
like you to use the
strategy that you
saw in the lecture,
which is find A inverse,
and then take A inverse b.
So we really want to practice
understanding how to find
the inverse of a matrix.
So why don't you work on
this, pause the video.
When you feel
comfortable, confident,
that you have the right answer,
then bring the video back up,
and you can compare
your work with mine.
OK, welcome back.
Well, hopefully you were
able to make some headway
and you feel confident in
your answers for 1 and 2.
I am going to find the
inverse of the matrix A first,
and then solve the problem.
And because there's
a lot of computation,
I may make a mistake.
So I'm going to have to
check every once in a while
that I'm doing OK.
So hopefully, it's-- too bad
you can't tell me if I've made
a mistake, but hopefully my
studio audience will help me
out.
So the first thing
I need to do is
I need to find the
determinant of A.
So I'm going to do
that first, and then
I'm going to find the cofactor
matrix and go from there.
So if I want to find
the determinant of A--
I guess I'll just use
the first row here,
because it's pretty easy.
So the determinant
of A is going to be
3 times the determinant of this
matrix, this 2-by-2 matrix.
So it's going to be
3 times-- and then I
get a 2 times negative
1, which is negative 2,
and then minus 0, so I
get a 3 times negative 2.
Oops.
And I was about to write plus,
but I should write minus.
I take minus 1 times--
because this is my minus,
I take negative of
this thing times
the matrix that is these two
components in the first column
and these two components
in the second column.
Right?
We take away the column and the
row that the 1 is contained in
and we look at what remains,
the 2-by-2 matrix that remains.
And we find the
determinant of that.
So we get negative 1 times
negative 1, which gives me a 1.
And then negative 1
times 0 gives me a 0.
So I just have the negative 1
from the row 1, column 2 spot,
and then the determinant
of the matrix that remains
is 1, OK-- of the minor
matrix that remains.
And then the last one
I should put a plus,
but notice that it
is a minus already,
so I'm going to put just
minus 1 times what remains.
What's this minor?
This one is this 2-by-2
matrix I'm looking at, right?
So I need to take
the determinant
of this 2-by-2 matrix and
multiply it by that negative 1
to get the third component
here I have to add in.
Negative 1 times
negative 1 is 1.
And then I subtract
negative 1 times 2.
So this is where I
have to be careful.
It's 1 minus negative 2.
So I'm going to get a 3.
OK.
1 here minus a negative 2-- so
1 plus 2-- I'm going to get a 3.
OK.
And so negative 6 minus
1 minus 3-- looks like I
get a negative 10.
That's good, because
I think that's what
I'm supposed to get.
OK.
Now what I want to do is I want
to find the matrix of minors
for A. And then
I'm going to find--
so I'm going to find the
matrix of minors first,
and then I'm going to switch
the signs appropriately
so I get the cofactors correct.
OK?
So some of them I already have.
But, the whole
matrix of minors, I'm
going to just go through and do
it again, to be very careful.
So the first one I delete.
For the first row
and column spot,
I delete row 1 and
column 1, and I
look at the determinant
of that matrix.
That's 2 times negative
1 is negative 2, minus 0,
so I get a negative 2 there.
For the first row, second
column I come back,
and I'm now again looking-- I'm
deleting this column and row,
and so I'm looking at the
determinant of this matrix.
So I get negative
1 times negative 1
is 1, minus 0, so I get a 1.
Again, I'm going to change
all the signs later.
So I'm going to do that
in the second step.
Now I'm in row 1, column 3.
So I'm going to delete
row 1, column 3 and look
at the determinant
of that matrix.
I get negative 1 times negative
1 is 1, minus the negative 2,
so there's my 3.
Those I already knew,
but I didn't want
to just plop them in from here.
But notice that is
what you get here.
Negative 2, 1, and 3.
That's exactly where
they come from, right?
We got them by the same method.
OK, and so now I want to find
the minors for the rest of it.
So let's look at-- when
I delete row 2, column 1,
I'm left with 1,
negative 1 here.
Negative 1, negative 1 here.
Right?
So 1 times negative
1 is negative 1.
And then negative and
negative is positive.
So it's negative 1
minus negative 1,
so I get negative 2.
That one was a lot of signs,
so you might want to check.
Maybe I should check.
OK, maybe I should check.
I'm deleting this
column and this row,
so I get 1 times negative 1.
That's a negative 1, right?
Negative 1 minus--
negative 1 times negative 1
is 1-- and so there's
negative 1 minus 1.
That looks good.
Negative 2.
Right?
Negative, negative, negative.
Yeah.
OK.
And then I'm looking
at row 2, column 2.
So now I'm deleting this
row and this column.
All right.
And so I have these
sort of diagonals here.
That's what I'm
interested in, right?
So I get 3 times negative 1.
That's negative 3.
And then minus 1, because I
have negative 1 times negative 1
is positive 1.
So negative 3 minus 1.
So I should get negative 4.
Right?
And then I'm over here.
So I need to delete this
column and this row.
So I get 3 times
negative 1 is negative 3.
Minus the negative
1, that's plus 1.
So negative 3 plus
1 is negative 2.
And before I go on, I'm going
to check those first 2 rows.
Because if I made a mistake now,
it's only going to get worse.
What did I have?
Yes.
OK.
So far so good.
Whew.
All right.
Next, final row.
OK, final row is, I'm
going to delete this column
and row here, and I'm
looking at this matrix.
1 times 0 is 0.
2 times negative 1 is negative
1, but I subtract that.
So it's 0 minus
negative 2, so it's 2.
And then row 3, column 2.
So row 3, I delete
row 3 and column 2.
3 times 0 is 0.
0 minus-- negative
1 times negative 1
is 1-- so 0 minus 1,
that's negative 1.
And then the last
spot, I'm deleting
this row and this column.
So 3 times 2 is 6,
minus negative 1.
I get 7.
All right, let's check that row.
2, negative 1, 7.
OK.
I have not done the
cofactor matrix yet,
because now I need to change
the appropriate signs.
OK, so if this is
the matrix of minors,
then if I want to change it
to the cofactor matrix, what
do I have to do?
I'm going to scratch this
out and write the cofactor
matrix so that we can just
change the signs appropriately.
I'm going to do
it all right here.
And how does it work?
Well, remember I'm going to go
plus, minus, plus; minus, plus,
minus; plus, minus, plus.
I have to do this grid
that starts with plus
and alternates minus.
So this sign stays the
same, this sign switches,
this sign stays the same.
That's the plus, minus, plus.
This one is going to
be minus, plus, minus.
So the minus switches that.
Plus keeps that the same.
Minus switches that.
And then I was at
minus, plus, minus.
So I'm going to have
plus, minus, plus.
And so these two stay the
same, and this one switches.
So a lot of things that were
negative became positive.
And I had to change-- maybe
I threw in one negative,
maybe not.
But, so all the signs I kept,
this one stayed the same,
these two stayed
the same, and then
these four switched,
because it's
the plus, minus,
plus sort of grid
that I have to put
on top of this.
OK, so that's the
cofactor matrix.
We're getting closer.
OK, now we need the
transpose of this, right?
So if I look at the
transpose-- actually,
know what I'm going to do?
Because I'm also just going
to have to take the transpose
and then multiply it by
1 over the determinant,
I'm going to do
that all at once.
OK.
Because we can do that
all at once, and then
we don't have to worry about it.
So A inverse I know is
going to be negative 1/10,
because the determinant
was minus 10.
So it's 1 over the determinant
times the transpose
of this matrix.
So the transpose
of this matrix--
remember what I'm going
to do is essentially
you fix the diagonal and
you're going to flip.
That's really what, in
the square matrix, that's
how you can think about it.
But every column is
going to become a row.
So I'm going to write
this as my first row.
This first column is going
to become my first row.
So it's going to be negative
2, 2, 2 as my first row.
And then the next
column is going
to be negative 1, negative 4, 1.
I mean next row.
I will take a column
and change it to a row.
The next row is going to be
negative 1, negative 4, 1.
And then the last one.
I take this column and
I change it to a row.
It's going to be 3, 2, 7.
OK.
And because again, I
want to make sure--
this one is really
messy-- I want
to make sure I have something
similar for that, or exactly
that.
OK.
I think I'm still
doing all right.
Now, let's get to
solving the problem.
Because so far, we just were
finding the inverse matrix.
So I'm going to leave
it in this form,
instead of dividing
by 10 in every spot,
because that will be annoying.
So let's think
about how do I want
to solve the system that I had.
I had A*x equals b.
And actually, I
mean, my strategy
is to find the inverse matrix.
I didn't talk to
you about why we
know the inverse
matrix actually exists.
But ultimately, you
haven't even seen this yet
in the lecture videos, really.
Except that you know that the
determinant of A being non-zero
gives you an inverse matrix.
That's all you know, I
think, at this point.
You have the determinant
of A. It's non-zero,
so you can find
an inverse matrix.
Makes sense based on the
formulation you have,
because if the determinant
is 0, then this quantity 1
over the determinant
of A, you run
into quite a bit of trouble.
So that's just as
a little sidebar,
we know the inverse
matrix exists for A.
So what we do-- this
is again the strategy--
you multiply A inverse A
times x on the left side.
Ooh.
Is equal to-- sorry-- that
should be the lowercase b.
Should be a vector there.
It is equal to A inverse
b on the right-hand side.
And you notice,
it's very important,
in the matrix
multiplication video
we saw that it's very
important the order in which
you multiply matrices.
And since I'm putting A
inverse on the far left
of this side of the equality, I
have to put it on the far left
of the right-hand
side of the equality.
Right?
And in fact, you
would run into trouble
if you tried to switch
the order of these.
OK?
We wouldn't be able
to multiply them.
All right?
So A inverse A, we know is
just the identity matrix.
So you get the
identity matrix times x
is equal to A inverse b.
So you can find x by
finding A inverse times b.
Right?
And so now we have A inverse.
Let's see if we can
solve the problem.
One point I want to make is that
now that you have A inverse--
I've tried to ask you to solve
the problem for two different
b's-- you don't have to go and
find A inverse again, right?
You're done finding A inverse.
You just now have to
do the multiplication.
So now for number
1, we had b was
equal to-- I'm going
to write it here,
so I don't have to keep looking
over-- 1, 2, negative 3.
So A inverse b is going
to be equal to-- well
I should get another
vector, so I should just
have three components here.
And I'm probably going to
have to write out what I get,
because it might be long.
But let's see-- actually,
you know what I'm
going to do to make it easier?
Because there's a lot
of junk going on here.
So what I'm going to
do to make it easier
is put the negative
1/10 in front to start.
Because that negative
1/10 is going
to come along with
every term, so I'm
just going to put the negative
1/10 in front and deal
with it at the end.
OK?
So now I'm just
going to multiply
b-- which is this 1, 2, negative
3-- by this big matrix here
without the negative
1/10 in front.
OK?
So let's look at that.
We're just going to have
first row times the column,
and that's going to give
me the first position.
So negative 2 times
1 is negative 2.
I'm going to write
them all down.
Plus 2 times 2 is 4.
Plus 2 times negative
3 is negative 6.
So that's the first position.
We'll simplify in a moment.
So the next one, I get
negative 1 times 1.
That's negative 1.
Then I get negative 4 times 2.
That's negative 8.
So minus 8.
And then I get 1 times
negative 3, so minus 3.
So we've got two
of the rows done.
We just have to simplify
them in a moment.
And now we just do
this third component.
So it's the third row of A
inverse without that scalar
in front, times the
only column of b
to give me the last position.
Right?
So 3 times 1 is 3, plus 2 times
2 is 4, so I get 3 plus 4,
and then 7 times
negative 3 is minus 21.
OK.
So what do I get when
I write it all out?
I get negative 1/10.
And then-- so negative 8 plus
4, that looks like a minus 4.
Right?
8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
That looks like a negative 12.
It's a lot of adding for me.
I make a lot of adding mistakes,
so we should be careful.
This looks like negative 14.
OK.
So this is a matrix that,
it's just a vector, right?
All the negative
signs will drop out.
I'll get some fractions.
But if it is the correct
answer-- which I'm really
hoping it is, because I
just did this whole problem
and I hope it's the
correct answer--
if it's the correct answer,
then what should it do?
When I take the original A
that I had and I multiply it
by this, I should get b.
I should get 1, 2, negative 3.
So you can check your work
very easily to see if it works.
You can take A times this,
and see if you get b.
Right?
And then you'll know if this
is the x we were looking for.
OK?
And then let's
look at number two.
I just said that b
equals [0, 0,  0].
And the point I
want to make there
is that since this
has an inverse,
A inverse-- since A has
an inverse, A inverse b
is going to be-- in this case--
A inverse times [0, 0, 0],
which is going to
give you [0,  0, 0].
So the only solution we have in
this case-- because A inverse,
if I look and I try and multiply
every row by this column,
right, I'm going to get
0 in the first spot,
0 in the second spot,
and 0 in the third spot--
so the solution I get-- the
x I'm looking for so that Ax
equals [0, 0, 0]-- is [0, 0, 0].
And what I just want
to mention to you,
is that that is true
because A is invertible.
If A were not invertible, you
could get other solutions.
Other things might work.
And that's also true,
actually, in this case as well,
but it's a little harder to
see that it's-- that could be
potentially a weird thing.
To solve A*x equals
[0, 0, 0], it's sort of like,
naturally we see
[0, 0, 0] is a solution.
Right away you can see that,
and that's one that we get.
The point I want to make
is because A is invertible,
that's the only solution.
And if A were not
invertible, you
could get other
solutions to that.
So that's something that
we haven't seen yet--
we haven't dealt
with yet-- but that
is something that can happen.
So I just want to point out that
there could be an oddity if A
were not invertible.
But since A is invertible,
we get just one solution
for both of these things.
OK.
So I'm going to go back
and just remind you
of a few things of how we
found the inverse matrix,
and then I will stop.
So we were given a
matrix A. And to go
through the steps of finding the
inverse matrix, what did we do?
The first thing we did was
we found the determinant.
Then we found the
matrix of minors.
And then I just took
that matrix of minors,
put the plus-minus
grid on top of it
so that I got the
cofactor matrix.
Right?
And then once I had
the cofactor matrix,
you just have to transpose it.
So I came over here.
I transposed that, and I put
1 over the determinant of A
in front.
So the scalar is 1 over
the determinant of A,
times the transpose of
the cofactor matrix.
And that's what
gives me A inverse.
So there are a fair
number of steps,
but you can do them
very systematically,
and then you have the inverse
matrix that you're looking for.
And then you can solve for x,
when you're looking for A*x
equals b, and you
know b and you know A.
And you do this same process
we just outlined here again,
and that gives it to you.
OK, I think I'll stop there.